en el vídeo anterior estudiamos de dónde
salió la ecuación del gas ideal presión
por volumen es igual al número de
moléculas por alguna constante por la
temperatura espero que ahora todo tenga
sentido para ustedes recuerden que vimos
como el volumen es inversamente
proporcional a la presión pero al
multiplicar ambos lados de la igualdad
el volumen no nos quedó dividiendo a
todo esto sino multiplicando a la
presión hagamos algunos problemas
sabiendo todo esto vamos a decir que
tenemos déjenme pensar digamos que
tenemos un contenedor de 2 litros
que sea un globo un globo de 2 litros
un blog
que contiene hidrógeno gaseoso
que contienen hidrógeno gaseoso está
compuesto por dos átomos de hidrógeno en
cada molécula la temperatura es de 30
grados celsius pongámoslo en otro color
30 grados celsius perdón 1% es 30 grados
celsius
y digamos que la presión por fuera del
globo es de dos atmósferas vamos a
ponerlo de otro color dos atmósferas
entonces mi pregunta es cuántos moles de
hidrógeno tenemos cuántos moles de
hidrógeno tenemos ok cuántos
molés bueno vamos a aplicar la ecuación
del gas ideal por supuesto dado que
tenemos litros y atmósferas hay que
asegurarnos de usar la constante
correcta pero en general
si tenemos presión la presión está dada
en atmósferas dejen escribir todas las
unidades dos atmósferas
que multiplica al volumen que es 2
litros
por 2 litros es igual a n n es el número
de partículas que nos interesan
vamos a notar en el número de moles que
multiplica er ikke constante r es la que
hay que usar déjenme escribir la de
todos modos al ratito lo vemos r por la
temperatura que está a 30 grados pero la
mayoría de las veces ya sea en problemas
de gases o de otro tipo se debe de usar
la temperatura en grados kelvin es decir
hay que convertirla vamos a ver un
pequeño repaso sobre grados kelvin
grados kelvin es una escala de
temperatura diferente la temperatura más
baja que se puede alcanzar en el
universo vamos a dibujar la escala de
temperatura aquí voy a poner
voy a poner dos una para grados celsius
y vamos a poner otra para grados kelvin
entonces la temperatura más baja que se
puede alcanzar en el universo es decir
también podemos verlo como que la
energía promedio de las moléculas o los
átomos es cero no se mueven es decir
están en un estado estacionario en
grados celsius este estado lo
encontramos a menos 273 punto 15 grados
celsius menos 273 punto 15 grados
celsius entonces el 0 estaría como por
aquí
por aquí el 0 en donde el agua se
congela y a 100 grados por acá en donde
el agua hierve como pueden darse cuenta
la escala de grados celsius se hizo con
base a los puntos en los que el agua se
congela o hierve ahora kelvin cuando
miran acá pueden encontrar 5 grados
celsius 10 grados celsius y se puede
pensar que a 10 grados existe el doble
de energía que a los 5 grados pero en
realidad no es así si nos vamos a donde
la energía es igual a 0 es decir la
temperatura absoluta para ver si puedo
dibujarlo los 10 grados van de aquí
hasta acá mientras que los 5 grados
llegan cerca pero se quedan antes
entonces los 10 grados son un ligero
incremento respecto a los 5 grados pero
no son el doble lo cual es un poco
confuso y por eso se trabaja mejor con
la escala de kelvin porque aquí el cero
absoluto es cero grados kelvin entonces
para los cero grados celsius
bueno el incremento es el mismo un grado
que cambian celsius es un grado que
cambian calvin entonces solo se hace un
pequeño ajuste que es sumar los 273
grados kelvin es decir que para 5 grados
celsius son 278 kelvin 10 grados son 283
kelvin y como pueden ver no son tan
diferentes entre sí pero en general
si queremos convertir descensos a kelvin
sólo hay que sumar los 273 grados
entonces los 30 grados celsius que están
como por aquí
son igual a 303 grados kelvin 30 grados
celsius es igual a 303 grados kelvin
ahora
vamos a sustituir entonces que la
temperatura es igual a 303
grados kelvin
ahora tenemos que encontrar qué
constante se usa aquí
recuerden estamos trabajando con
atmósferas y con litros
aquí abajo escribí algunos de los
valores de esta constante r en distintas
unidades todos coinciden en moles y
kelvin entonces deberemos usar esta
constante r es igual a punto 0 82 litro
atmósfera por mol kelvin déjenme
escribirlo acá arriba
escribiré toda la ecuación otra vez dos
atmósferas por dos litros es igual a n
por punto punto 0 82 litro atmósfera por
mol kelvin
por 300 perdón por 303 grados kelvin
veamos que podemos hacer con esto
tenemos que asegurarnos de que las
unidades estén bien es como estudiar a
los números si dividimos ambos lados
entre atmósfera por ejemplo atmósfera y
atmósfera se cancela si dividimos entre
litros litro y litro se cancela este que
elvin en el denominador cancela a este
entonces nos queda 2 por 2 es igual a n
por punto 0 punto 0 82 por
303 y aquí sólo tenemos uno entre mol
entonces el número de moles lo que hay
que despejar esa n hay que quitar esto
de aquí ya sea dividiendo todo esto o
simplemente pasándolo del otro lado nos
queda 2 por 2 4
/ punto 0 82 por 303 y así como pasamos
los números que están multiplicando
dividiendo el mol que aquí está
dividiendo hay que pasarlo multiplicando
n es igual a los moles entonces las
unidades son correctas me quedara un
resultado en moles y cuántos moles son 4
entre 0.0 82 entre 303 es igual a punto
16 vamos a ponerlo es igual a punto 16
moles de h2 esto me dice el número
exacto de moles de hidrógeno
pero si queremos saber el número de
moléculas habría que multiplicar esto
por 6.0 2 por 10 a la 23 y claro si
quieren saber cuál es la masa de
hidrógeno que tenemos bueno un gol
un mod
th 2 tiene una masa de la masa de un
solo hidrógeno es una unidad de masa
atómica por lo que la masa de dos
moléculas es dos unidades de masa
atómica entonces un molde h2 es igual a
dos gramos nosotros tenemos punto 16
moles para convertirlo a gramos ni
siquiera necesitó la calculadora en este
caso serían punto 32 gramos sólo
multiplicamos por 2 porque cada mol
equivale a 2 gramos de cualquier forma
hay que hacer más problemas de estos
como pudieron ver creo que la matemática
que usamos es simple en lo que hay que
prestar atención es en las unidades que
usamos si usamos metros cúbicos en lugar
de litros o kilopascales en lugar de
atmósferas hay que asegurarse de revisar
las unidades y usar las constantes
adecuadamente